today's topic can you repeat the
question one more time I like how the
Mexican guys like I don't understand
your Indian accent from one brown person
to her she cuz how do we dismantle anti
black you see nobody even I was like
thank you for putting the subtitles it's
very rare that the producer has to put
subtitles for their own accent I'm not
mad at the accent cuz I like it I seek
to make people that feel anti blackness
that are that are struck by the sight of
it or the existence of it this guy
speaks like a poet I feel that I have to
speak the way that I beat like a bird
yes you're heard the way I soar through
the skies girl I'm taking a piece of the
pie it's mine
it's time it's Himes singing within
churches girl you know I got the blur
chah's huh that's not a word
yeah you know you're heard ha ha ha
since Santa he never came with the
presence Why Why What I don't know I
stayed up with all them cookies she la
la la you don't want more poets
I never da da da I stay in the poets
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've got that
Ephraim yay
do you got the Afro I don't have the
Afro I have to pick
I have to pick that's why I get picked
picked into the line where I get picked
off by the cops cops
segregation goin through my veins and
like the slave blood of the slave body
of the King King King Dean's
that's the sound of the Bell my man just
tapped out
that's the sound of a hell we've broken
out on our way to heaven girl there is
no safe haven for black people we are
the people that brought you goodness my
goodness your goodness your hood miss
your highness
tanks things pains in your hair nappy
with the pick pick me but I ain't no
pick me [ __ ] I got a turban on but I'm
not a Sikh to do that feeling birds like
I'm feeling self self self ha who's that
replying to my self self self I don't
know gosh sorry how can I beat anti in
my inner circle I wonder if they're
gonna ask this question of black people
of course not we can't we can't be
entire our existence our entire I
remember I feel bad calling my family
out we were at the DMV once and my mom
made a comment about well you're in
America you should speak English because
someone was speaking to their family
member and I think in Middle Eastern
language and I do find that annoying
though I do find it annoying when two
people are having a conversation between
each other and then this random folk
personals come I black why won't you
speak English it's our private
conversation we do things the way that
we want to do are you eavesdropping why
you need to know Jamie this is that
insecurity that gets on my nerves and it
happened here it happens here too a
whole lot
ah dokey big [ __ ] stop it like I'm not
talking to you yeah if there's one thing
that if you're receiving the service and
the person's not speaking one of the
official language that I understand but
if two people are having a private
conversation mind your business
when you stop being such a nosy ass
person within like the Hispanic
community a common comment that's
brought up is that they don't want their
daughters and sons to marry or date
black people that's the fact jack this
is not something I heard secondhand
either first hand I had girlfriends
would be like yo my dad is really upset
that you're black it's a reality out of
my entire family I'm actually the only
one who is in support of the black lives
matter movement and it is very difficult
to talk to my family one thing that I
want to do is to get together and
perhaps have like a movie night and
suggest for example 13th that does
explore the concept of systemically in
the hood 30% 13th is actually good
documentary on Netflix that you can
watch right now for free on YouTube
there I remember the first slur when I
was like four or five these guys were
like your skin looks like poop you know
you just Mel like we don't know play
with you you're the color so it was kind
of like okay I knew from very young that
I was gonna encounter
you know these attitudes a typical one
yeah yielded lights check air how's it
typical so much memories in Hispanic
culture we refer to some African
Americans as negative thoughts not all I
just sound like good drink can I have to
make it eat those please delicious bro
he tones and it rhymes with Nikki oh
yeah like a good-looking drink alright
so they had a full day worth of training
and in this training someone opened up
in that conversation and she was saying
how she's a white woman who has a son
who's a white male a teenager and she
has recently been so fearful of how he's
interpreting everything in the way that
he might be exposed to a group of people
who have a mindset that you know black
lights don't matter okay she just was
fearful of her son being because I
wanted to say sure he's doing his best
HR voice CBI officer use HR thing yeah
yeah he works in human resources so
letting me human reset me let me listen
it got her so emotional that she was in
tears because she was asking for help
how do i educate my son to make sure he
understands this and just by having that
conversation you know it opened up a lot
of doors it's seen as unprofessional to
have braids or to have twists hey she's
back
you don't remember her know what it is
it's a girl from the other video where
they have to do guess who's black and
they had blindfold oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you just think about the
booty huh
dirty fellow I don't know I believe
dirty said but I do have a sweet tooth I
like cakes let's go good to see you
again and those are protective styles of
black women and men black women are
three to four times more likely than
white women to die in childbirth and
that's because there's these stereotypes
that black women are strong and
aggressive compared to white women being
fragile and feminine
and so it really has an impact on how
black people express their pains and how
its received by health care
professionals
it is important to listen and you want
to listen with the intent to understand
a lot of times people listen with the
intent to reply to everything and we
just want to be understood we have to
put defenses down and stop assuming that
an easy thing that every individual can
do is to vote you know on your local
level your local government on for the
presidential election there was a
certain point that I just do not I was
not a track I didn't was not attracted
to like black folks like black men and I
think it's because of the implicit bias
that I had growing up I try to recognize
we've done myself in certain situations
and I try to fight against it and now
you take black tea because you know this
is supposed to be profound but it really
doesn't feel like it so I can't feel
like I'm connecting when I understand I
understand if you want to see it's
police brutality or problem you can just
look it up it's right there America it's
oftentimes the real color that they see
is green and if we can research where we
put our money and see what they're doing
with it who are they donating it to are
they can using your money to oppress
black people then you need to take your
dollars and put it into companies that
are more progressive this is by far the
best answer I've heard this whole time
thus far that in the voting person had
the most insightful answers the reality
is a lot of these racial problems are
solved by green by money Americans are
way more capitalistic than the are true
ok slavery wasn't born because they
hated black people they were born
because they loved money and by virtue
they want a cheap labor so they went
through slaves but be rest assured they
the real color they see first is green
and then from there everything else is
born Jackie Robinson Jackie Robinson yes
there are more about their money than
they worry about like right there
because gonna fill hate black people but
that that dude he was so talented he was
so talented I'm like I'm more about my
capital then I'm about my morals yes
so this isn't to absolve the mama let
him play okay that's what happened yeah
I'm sorry I thought I had so many good
things to say
use whatever privilege you can to
amplify black voices they say I talk
with like oh you're the whitest black
girl I've ever met and I hate it I've
always hated it but in the moment I'm
like ah haha but it's not okay
being brave that sounds probably silly
but I think it can be really really hard
to have conversations like this and just
taking the first step of like opening it
up even when it's really uncomfortable
anti is not a one day thing it is
something that will take the rest of our
lives do you know I think I realized I
think I'm so biased against to believe
that this video started I was just like
no and then they had that whole like in
the dark low light the music playing in
the background as if something profound
was being said but it feels like it's
just advice you'd hear often that being
said in the day they're trying to do a
good thing they're trying to put in a
positive spin on this whole issue so you
can't fault them for that I'd be curious
to see more tangible examples of what
that looks like did I feel like they
talked about a lot of these things in
the abstract but I think it's hard to
put an image on what those things look
like unless you've seen them in
application use your privilege to help
black people great well how means how
but how do you do that but I glad to do
that look like for you I feel like if
they would have come at this with more
personal examples to showcase how that
would have been great like the person
who said vote that's an effective way to
put pressure I like that idea
so persons have my money right point
pressure in that regard I really like
that idea but for the rest of them
everything was abstract and I felt like
because of that it was hard for me to
really connect because I'm tired of
hearing abstract I'm tired of hearing
all guys I support you what does that
mean though you know when he talked
talking about amplifying a black voice
it's a bit what they did at that
blackout Tuesday you know the big sale
today at stop sale but it really sounded
like
it's really like for a day set up for
all the black voice to be heard I
understand why it is there and why would
he mean by amplifying and yes at some
point he means shutting up but I mean
that's not my way of doing things
whenever I want to understand something
I had to be able to do a back and forth
thing up never really work when I was in
school I didn't just stay there and shut
up the class I was performing the most
was when I was able to have it back and
forth with a teacher when I was I were
able to raise my hand and question some
things and even challenge something that
he was saying so I can better understand
hang up wouldn't have helped it I get
what you're saying but it doesn't mean I
agree with it it doesn't mean that I
understand it it doesn't mean that I
approve of it it's just me that I got
that information doesn't mean that I
agree so the back and forth they amplify
the back voice sure I understand where
that's from but if we're not able to
have like a discussion what's the point
then that's pretty much what I think
tell us what do you think don't forget
we have a patreon we have the podcast as
well and you know don't forget you can
hit that like button that subscribe
button that bell ding a ling a dong
leave a comment you know algorithm helps
us so thank you very much for being here
you know tell us what you think
[Music]
you